Stacy's with us in Atlanta hi Stacy how
are you fine thanks for asking
we wasn't sure how can I help listen um
I have a car and it's amis ADEs so it's
chemists Benson but my dream car but my
boyfriend says that I should get a less
go down you know what am I saying
um he thinks your car's too expensive
yeah yeah so how much do you owe on your
Mercedes
nine thousand nine hundred ninety five
to the site you owe $10,000 on your
Mercedes that's correct
what is the car worth um I asked my
credit union and they were willing to
give me seven but I did the Kelley Blue
Book and it's an 18 okay something from
some thumbs ins off right so somebody's
got some bad information either you did
Kelly Blue Book wrong or your credit
union looked it up wrong so go to Kelly
Blue Book now when you did that did you
look at retail or our private sale um
retail okay
won't you go back and enter the numbers
and again when I did the week I looked
at the retail as well - okay um blah
blah 17 I wasn't too bad
oh okay women you just told me retail
was 18 and you said I looked at the
retail and it was 7 sigh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
that's what private sale was 17 yeah
okay well the credit union information
must be off what year mersa what model
and year Mercedes is it it is AC 340
what year 2010 yeah it's probably 17
okay all right it's a great little car
what is your income I'm ASA proximately
28 here well here's a rule of thumb
okay Mercedes is a great car I actually
have a GL I have one of the SUV's from
them and so it's a fabulous car and with
the car you've got it's a really nice
car you're right but here's the thing
I've learned and here's what your
boyfriend's pointing out Stacey if you
want to become wealthy okay so that you
can drive whatever you want to drive and
live your dreams and be able to be
generous to others you have to
understand that when you have money tied
up in things you have a lot of money
tied up in things going down in value
it's very difficult to become wealthy
wealthy people put money and things are
going up in value okay so the rule of
thumb that I use is and you and I both
know cars go down in value pretty
quickly pretty quickly they're pretty
much a black hole for money right okay
so yes this is a sweet car but as a
percentage of your world I mean you make
twenty foot you make 28 and you have 20
in a car it's the biggest thing you own
and it's going the wrong way in value
and so it is out of line you have too
much tied up in things going down in
value and it's not to say the car is not
nice let's not say you don't deserve a
nice car my question is what are your
goals if your goals are to ten years
from now on an old Mercedes and still be
broke that's you're right on track okay
you can keep them you can keep doing
exactly what you're doing if that's your
goal you're going to hit your goal but
if I'm you my goal is to be making 48 or
58 ten years from now and have paid for
car and some money in the bank okay that
would be my goals that makes sense
oh yes yeah so you just got too much
tied up in this car and you bought the
car because it was cool and because some
idiot loaned you the money mm-hmm and it
just you know but I think your
boyfriend's probably on track there I
think he's probably giving you some good
advice to stop and look at that now
again someday if the what am I believe
is if you live like no one else you pay
a price to win later you get to live
like no one else and so I you know when
I went broke Stacy several years ago I
drove junk cars for a while and now I
don't know I don't drive a junk car
anymore because I drove junk cars for a
while he lived like no one else later
you get to live and give like no one
else you drive like no
one else later you get to drive like no
one else and so that's that's the more
of the story here and so you can't act
like you're rich when you're not it'll
cause you to be broke your whole life
and you didn't mean to necessarily you
didn't say I'm trying to show off or
something you just found a really sweet
cool car and went I want this car and
you never really stop to think about
what it's going to do to damage to your
to your future and so I think he's
giving you good mature advice you do
need to move down in the car so if it
were me and I woke up in your shoes I
would sell the car for 17 and I would
buy paid for seven thousand dollar car
no payments and then I'd start investing
and building some wealth and get my
income up keeping my career on track and
move up in car with cash as you go along
that's how I would do it if I woke up in
your shoes good question thank you for
calling in honored to have you in our
audience this is the Dave Ramsey show